ABB's inside by Jarnell Stokes on the
other wing with three bran 36 Simon's
will take another hate it go through
them and get a bucket
Simon's bangs in another three we're not
even in fits into this game could be
interesting very interesting you've seen
guys already you never see guys make
three in a row try another Hey
when you do you see it make five in a
row don't go to college go to IMG learn
to shoot
you know you've one star every team's
will have a star yeah surround it with
really good play outside of five guys
they had a bunch of guys who can really
play these four it's pretty good bye
silence
rebound secured by Portland here comes
Simon's cutting between two flipping it
up and in 21 for Anthony Simon's short
Trent the rebound blasting ahead with
Simon's to his left lobs it up to her
- nope snow bucket and the rebound ends
up with Simon's time it's through the
lane protein baking layups is nutty look
at this he's off balance he's floating
through keeps his chin on them see what
he can do for me
he may lose a game boy let's see what he
can do Simon so all this smooth stroke
pretty Simon's now six of six from deep
in some Simon's Junior Simon's cradles
it ain't pretty Simon's with 31 points
on 11 of 15 should actually hit you last
but they also see that I slapped your
wrist and that's why it hit you last why
should it be your ball
[Applause]